hi my name is Julian I like Tom sport
for Southeast Asian mafia I have a
question here from other facebook fans
the question is llegando sample of
Indonesia the question is happily
increasing access to a popular to
education but also they develop in
countries I live and breathe the
internet and one of the things that I've
seen is the internet is about our
knowledge economy and when you increase
access to information of pronouncing
accessing the internet or other sources
it helps develop an education are one of
the things about the internet is you
know hit increase access to means they
can see what's going on understand
filtration understand patience we will
have happened you're the one it's you
can access to ideas and connectivity
with the rest of the world through
facebook twitter and and those other
social media so the last thing is
technology really information age so
I've epidemics infantry talaga Vietnam
where access to information and access
to technology that is related to the
internet like HTML has really helped
people educate yourselves learn about
things without having a formal education
and classroom eventually we'll learn how
to program I'll learn how to do a lot of
things create apps and things like that
that really help them understand and
push themselves into the new information
image and so my my suggestion
Institute's the cheap analysis make it
easy to access the future to the
internet and it's cheaper